a day after the pope's visit to
parliament a huge welcome for another
man
seen by millions as a light of hope the
savior of women and communities
terrorized in the war-torn democratic
republic of congo
dr dunim mukwege winner of this year's
sakharov prize for freedom of thought
a gynecologist who's transformed the
lives of tens of thousands of victims of
rape and mutilation
i'm
dr mukwege runs the pansy hospital in
northeastern drc
where he and his team have treated women
with horrific internal wounds
resulting from sexual violence by
congolese and neighboring rebels
all of whom are fighting for control of
the resource-rich area
a man who says he studied medicine to
heal the sick people his father could
only pray for
a man who has consistently demanded drc
and the world
and rape as a weapon of war
a theme echoed by president schultz who
spelled out some necessary but
elementary steps
for those living in the shadow of drc's
never-ending violence who traveled a
long way to see the prize awarded
it was a moving
from inside the parliament itself some
reactions the kind of work he does
if he gets more recognition with his
prize and gets more recognition to him
is something which is good for all of us
those women
they need and the girls because most of
them were girls
they need that public opinion knows what
is happening in congo
dr mukwege survived an assassination
attempt several years ago and fled with
his family to europe
he returned last year to a hero's
welcome little is going to stop this man
universally recognized as a medical
pioneer driven by
deep compassion